en ethiopie ce que l'on craint le plus
ce n'est pas la deuxième vague de la
coved 19 mais bien un déluge de cliquer
la pire invasion du genre depuis un
quart de siècle des nuages de criquets
qui peuvent parcourir jusqu'à 130 km par
jour et détruire tout sur leur passage
ils diront fait pousser des céréales sur
cinq hectares dans la région de kombucha
au nord-est de l'île aux pies chambre un
teint il ne sait plus s'il arrivera à
nourrir ses sept enfants
et s'il pourra les envoyer à l'école
après ce cauchemar dit il depuis le mois
de janvier les cris qui ont ravagé
l'équivalent de 280 terrain de football
un seul kilomètre carré de ces terres
permettrait de nourrir chaque jour 35
mille personnes qui ces régions le lion
des environnements fragiles
cette spécialiste ont inquiétés sur
tropicale sonne l'alarmé et les certains
cas à très court terme
des milliers personnes qui auront
n'auront pas de nourriture à manger
cette année la nuée de criquets
proviendraient du yémen pays affectés
par un conflit qui l'empêchent de
s'attaquer aux fléaux
à cela s'ajoutent les pluies diluviennes
survenues l'an dernier et qui aurait
favorisé la prolifération des insectes
dans le secteur face à l'urgence d'agir
albert l'ema sully un agriculteur du
coin géolocalise en moto les
recoupements des criquets pour mieux les
neutraliser
pour leur part les nations unies dont la
chaîne en approvisionnement en
pesticides a été paralysé par la
pandémie tant bien que mal d'apporter
leur aide
deux avions pulvérise déjà des
pesticides sur les terres de la région
ici gabriel proulx radio-canada bon